[Music]
the show of seed takes place in my world
Werner characters who have adapted to
living blind to build a world out any
time to think and to do research or to
feel real and grounded as the blindness
consultant on the show see a trained
actors how we moved through the world
and helped them understand how people
utilize their senses in a different way
we wanted to highlight the way we could
evolve as a result of losing sight
anytime you take away a sense and focus
on your other senses you'll pick up
information in a different way
most important piece for me it's the
daily rituals the nod of the head
there's no nod of the head in this way
there's a touch there's a way of
assuring or saying yes we have to
translate human behavior into a kind of
deeper listening
[Music]
Merilee talking ttyn I play Sutor Beck's
I was born with something called broad
cone dystrophy which means that I have
no central vision growing up I never saw
anyone like me on any television shows
and right now I get to be that person I
think I always kind of felt that my
disability would stop me from being on
camera this show helps continue to open
up the conversation to diversity and
it's setting a precedent for disabled
actors being seen just as capable
procedure
I feel Savage in Tanzania
most people don't imagine blind people
doing stunts on TV
gradually Holly was there trying to do a
better job of reflecting the world and
yet you seem very view visually impaired
people on screen we wanted to represent
them as warriors we wanted to represent
them as powerful we have that
opportunity with this show
representation is everything my deepest
hope is that we're creating change with
it
[Music]
you
[Music]